who they can't be with?
They ain't got that power.
Nobody has that power to say, you can't marry that young lady.
Who has that power? Nobody.
SM: But you know what?
Our state has put the power in your hands,
and so what we need you to do
is vote for, you gonna vote for 6.
Man 2: I got you.
SM: Vote for 6, okay? Man 2: I got you.
KSM: All right, do y'all need community service hours?
You do? All right, you can always volunteer with us
to get community service hours.
Y'all want to do that?
We feed you. We bring you pizza.
(Laughter) (Applause)
Yoruba Richen: Thank you.
What's amazing to me about that clip
that we just captured as we were filming
is, it really shows how Karess
understands the history of the civil rights movement,
but she's not restricted by it.
She doesn't just limit it to black people.
She sees it as a blueprint
for expanding rights to gays and lesbians.
Maybe because she's younger, she's like 25,
she's able to do this a little bit more easily,
but the fact is that Maryland voters
did pass that marriage equality amendment,
and in fact it was the first time
that marriage equality was directly voted on
and passed by the voters.
African-Americans supported it at a higher level
than had ever been recorded.
It was a complete turnaround from that night
in 2008 when Proposition 8 was passed.
It was, and feels, monumental.
We in the LGBT community have gone
from being a pathologized and reviled
and criminalized group
to being seen as part of the great human quest
for dignity and equality.
We've gone from having to hide our sexuality
in order to maintain our jobs and our families
to literally getting a place at the table
with the president
and a shout out at his second inauguration.
I just want to read what he said
at that inauguration:
"We the people declare today
that the most evident of truths,
that all of us are created equal.
It is the star that guides us still,
just as it guided our forebears
through Seneca Falls
and Selma and Stonewall."
Now we know that everything is not perfect,
especially when you look at what's happening
with the LGBT rights issue internationally,
but it says something about how far we've come
when our president puts the gay freedom struggle
in the context of the other great freedom struggles
of our time: the women's rights movement
and the civil rights movement.
His statement demonstrates not only
the interconnectedness of those movements,
but how each one borrowed
and was inspired by the other.
So just as Martin Luther King
learned from and borrowed from Gandhi's tactics
of civil disobedience and nonviolence,
which became a bedrock of the civil rights movement,
the gay rights movement saw what worked
in the civil rights movement,
and they used some of those same strategies
and tactics to make gains
at an even quicker pace.
Maybe one more other reason
for the relative quick progress
of the gay rights movement.
Whereas a lot of us continue to still live
in racially segregated spaces,
LGBT folks, we are everywhere.
We are in urban communities
and rural communities,
communities of color, immigrant communities,
churches and mosques and synagogues.
We are your mothers and brothers
and sisters and sons.
And when someone that you love
or a family member comes out,
it may be easier to support their quest for equality.
And in fact, the gay rights movement
asks us to support justice and equality
from a space of love.
That may be the biggest, greatest gift
that the movement has given us.
It calls on us to access that which is most universal
and most intimate:
a love of our brother and our sister
and our neighbor.
I just want to end with a quote
by one of our greatest freedom fighters
who's no longer with us, Nelson Mandela
of South Africa.
Nelson Mandela led South Africa
after the dark and brutal days of Apartheid,
and out of the ashes of that legalized racial discrimination,
he led South Africa to become the first country
in the world to ban discrimination
based on sexual orientation within its constitution.
Mandela said,
"For to be free is not merely to cast off one's chains,
but to live in a way that respects
and enhances the freedom of others."
So as these movements continue on,
and as freedom struggles around the world continue on,
let's remember that not only are they interconnected,
but they must support and enhance each other
for us to be truly victorious.
Thank you.
(Applause)